nous entamons ce soir une série
d'entrevues avec les quatre chefs des
principaux partis ce soir françoise
david elle se prépare essentiellement
aujourd'hui pour ce deuxième débat qui
se présente et vous le savez sur les
ondes de tva
on l'a rencontrée quand même ce midi
dans le quartier rosemont à la dans une
librairie fort sympathique la librairie
paulines sur la rue masson
voici ce que ça donne rencontre avec
françoise david
françoise david bonsoir bonsoir madame
david il ya quelqu'un qui m'ont écrit
hier en disant c'est incroyable cette
campagne le manque de hauteur on se
lance la boue d'un côté comme de l'eau
elle vous découragez de voir la lure de
cette fin de campagne
mais je ne sais pas si c'est la fin
disons il reste quand même une semaine
mais disons depuis une semaine depuis le
dernier débat des chefs en fait c'est
l'intégrité qui a pris le dessus et là
comme le dit un de mes amis c'est du
gard aux charges de boîtes de tous bords
tous côtés
c'est drôle nous autres qui al'air
d'émerger là dedans comme des
incorruptibles en fait je très contente
parce que c'est ce qu'on est
mais oui un petit côté décourageant une
journée c'est une journée c'est l'eau
parce que ça fait c'est que la
population se dit beaucoup donc tous
pareils
donc ça apporte pas de confiance
encourage le cynisme et moi j'espère que
là dedans les gens vont se rendre compte
que il y en a un le dernier gaulois qui
lui dit non nous on est incorruptible
mais est ce que vous trouvez que on doit
par exemple reparler du mandat libéral
de jean charest ce qu'on doit refaire
cette campagne lock on a un peu faire en
2012 mais que à travers la campagne on
reparle dès 9 ans de règne du régime
libéral oui monsieur couillard on a
quand même fait partie pendant plusieurs
années il était là au moment où l'on
commencé à entendre des allégations de
corruption et de collusion ça se peut
pas que tout lui est complètement
échappé mais évidemment on saura jamais
le fond de l'histoire alors qu'il y ait
quelques inquiétudes
oui et en fait ce que les gens de le
savoir c'est ce que monsieur couillard
rompt définitivement avec l'héritage
chars et puis là dessus vous aurez
remarqué les plus tôt et 20 inscrits
d'après vous devrez aller plus loin par
exemple pour dire car et il fait du
ici les vérités l'assemblée nationale
quand beaucoup de gens exigent une
commission denquête oui la réponse que
je vous donne c'est oui en fait vous me
suggérer une très bonne question pour ce
soir ça serait intéressant que monsieur
couillard nous 10 1 est ce que lui s'est
adonné à des pratiques de collusion
pendant qu'il était à l'assemblée
nationale est ce que lui aurait voulu et
est-ce qu'il s'est prononcé en faveur
d'une d'une enquête sur la construction
oui ou non ce serait intéressant et sur
le financement des partis politiques
dernières questions sur l'éthique est ce
qu'il n'ya pas aussi un peu d'hypocrisie
ambiante
le parti québécois a aussi eu recours à
certains de ces stratagèmes l'a
peut-être pas dans la même ampleur dont
le verre un jour mais on le sait s'est
avéré il ya eu le rapport moisan
on le sait que le parti québécois en
tout cas dans les années 90 c'est aller
jusque dans les années 2000
ça je ne le sais pas mais oui il a
utilisé les prête-noms
québec solidaire a sorti un rapport
lathus en 2010 que personne ne contestez
donc oui l'ensemble la classe politique
dans les années 90 utilisé ce stratagème
donc vous pouvez être agacé par monsieur
couillard mais aussi agacé par madame
marois qui se drapent de blanzat ou pq
c'est pas ça surtout quand elle dit au
pq nous ne l'avons jamais fait allons
donc
c'est ce n'est pas exact maintenant est
ce que c'est un c'est le seul débat que
nous devons faire durant cette campagne
non ce soir par les moins quelques
secondes de ce débat ce que vous
attendez vraiment que ce soit beaucoup
plus dures comme temps comme attaque par
rapport à la dernière fois ça pourrait
l'être mais en même temps comme ils sont
tous les trois un peu concernés disons
par les questions d'intégrité
ils vont peut-être se garder une petite
gêne là parce qu'un attaque l'autre
contre attaque
et puis au bout de 5 minutes vous l'avez
vu c'est la cacophonie totale
donc je ne sais pas moi de toute façon
la façon dont je me suis préparé
c'est de pouvoir intervenir sur cette
question là mais surtout surtout de dire
aux gens qui nous écoutent
il ya un parti il s'appelle québec
solidaire et lui ce prix qu ils se
préoccupent pardon des enfants dans les
écoles
il se préoccupe des malades qui
attendent l eau
gensse et se préoccupe de pauvreté ils
se préoccupent d'environnement on est
les seuls à en parler on va même ce soir
essayé de parler de langue et de culture
c'est pour vous dire parce que sa
personne ou à peu près n'en parle
donc on voudrait un peu élevé le débat
et la portée sur les préoccupations
quotidiennes des gens qu'est ce que vous
avez
selon vous apporter avec vous à
l'assemblée nationale qu'est ce que ça
change dans la dynamique et l'assemblée
nationale qui est 2 député de québec
solidaire ce que ça change c'est à
certains moments d'avoir un groupe qui
est la conscience de l'assemblée
nationale par exemple sur les compteurs
intelligents c'est nous qui avons
apporté une motion finalement adopté à
l'unanimité pour dit il faut absolument
que les gens qui décident de ne pas en
avoir ne soient pas pénalisés c'est nous
qui avons déposé une motion elle aussi
adoptée à l'unanimité pour dire faut
cesser la discrimination ratio mère à
l'aide sociale qui reçoivent une pension
alimentaire et ne peuvent pas la garder
c'est mon collègue amir khadir qui a été
le seul durant la commission
parlementaire sur l'inversion des
pipelines enbridge
ça a été le seul à poser des vraies
questions et ça a été saluée par
plusieurs journalistes je pense qu'on
essaie ça quelque part la conscience la
sens une époque vous n'êtes pas que des
pelleteux de nuages dans une utopie
politique que dans des dossiers concrets
le fait que vous soyez là sa force et
autres partis en faire un peu plus à se
positionner exactement
est-ce qui se positionne toujours comme
on voudrait bien sûr que non à gauche
c'est nous mais l'idée section lieu des
2 on était cinq dix quinze ou vingt puis
un jour 63
là ça changerait tout donc à deux on
fait tout ce qu'on peut imaginer si on
était plus il ya eu des appels du parti
québécois encore récemment à voter
stratégique a donc revenir au parti
québécois pour ne pas laisser passer
le parti libéral qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cet appel
ben que premièrement ça marche pas parce
que les sondages nous indique que nous
maintenant toujours au même niveau donc
nos électeurs ne nous déserte pas et
bien au contraire dans quelques régions
notre grande surprise l'électorat
augmente on en est extrêmement contents
nous qui voulons absolument sortir de
montréal et s'est toujours fait de
laisser passion libéral ou solide
d'accord quand même garder pour le
moment comme le 7 avril bon il ya peu de
chances qu'on prenne le pouvoir disons
le comme ça ça vient petit peu trop vite
ce qui serait pas mal ça serait un
gouvernement minoritaire
quels qu'ils soient et de donner à
québec solidaire la balance du pouvoir
là on aurait de l'influencé justement si
c'était moi et je veux terminer là
dessus françoise david s'il ne manquait
que deux prenons le scénario minoritaire
du parti québécois par exemple par
exemple il manque deux députés par
exemple vous êtes de l'assemblée
nationale est ce que vous seriez prête
même à les rejoindre les rangs des
banquettes du gouvernement avec père
capitaine rejoindre les banquettes du
gouvernement et donc devenir une sorte
de députés péquistes la réponse c'est
non mais oui à discuter ensemble à
s'assurer que le projet de loi qui est
déposée correspond aux cris avec le
groupe correspond au bien commun
correspondait valeurs d'écologie et là
oui on va voter avec le gouvernement
mais je vous souligne qu on le fait à
maintes reprises et si c'était un
gouvernement libéral minoritaire la même
chose on négocierait ont négocié raifort
on essaierait d'obtenir ce qu'on veut et
on pourrait voter avec ce gouvernement
s'il va dans le sens de la justice et de
l'écologie pour le bien du québec qu'est
ce que vous croyez que c'est mieux
d'avoir un gouvernement libéral ou
péquiste pour le bien du québec
sincèrement là ce qui vaut mieux c'est
de remettre en question les vieux partis
qui ont fait leur temps et de voter pour
québec solidaire sincèrement on est
rendu là vais pas de préférence mais
mieux je n'ai pas de préférence
ma préférence c'est ce que nous nous
apportons c'est un québec audacieux qui
se lance dans le 21e siècle qui fait du
transport en commun qui élimine les
gaspillages qui va chercher du nouvel
argent pour financer des programmes
sociaux
c'est de ça qu'on a besoin au québec et
vous rêvez d'un troisième
être avec vous deux je ne fais pas que
rêver nos voulons sincèrement avoir
d'autres députés et nous y travaillons
très très très fort françoise avait de
bons débats ni reçoit merci merci